I'm Jennifer and I'm Angela Kinsey. In our lives, we have worked in real offices and one very famous fake office. And now we're here to give you advice on your workplace dilemmas. Is only two best friends who worked in a fake office together can. We can't promise it will be good advice, but we'll try. Welcome to Dear Office Ladies. Hello! What's up, Dear Office Lady? Oh my gosh!
我是詹妮弗，我是安吉拉·金赛。在我们的生活中，我们曾在真正的办公室工作过，也曾在一家非常著名的虚构办公室工作过。现在我们在这里，以两个曾在虚构办公室共事的好友的身份，为你解决职场困惑。我们不敢保证建议一定管用，但我们会尽力。欢迎收听《亲爱的办公室女士》。你好！怎么了，亲爱的办公室女士？天哪！
I love her little theme. I do too. Thank you to Jordan Duffy. She composed that for us. So great, so fun. We're really excited to be here. We're doing something new today. That's right.
我喜欢她的小主题曲。我也喜欢。感谢乔丹·达菲，这是她为我们创作的。太棒了，太有趣了。我们很高兴能来到这里。我们今天要做一些新的尝试。没错。
So here's what's happening. A while back, if you remember, Cassie's friend and coworker Emma had this great idea of us doing an episode where we hear all about your offices and maybe give you some advice on your workplace dilemmas. So we asked you guys to write us with your work life advice questions, and we got over 1500 emails in one week. I know. It was crazy. So, we're going to jump in and see what we can do to help you solve your problems.
事情是这样的。前段时间，如果你还记得的话，凯西的朋友兼同事艾玛有个很棒的主意，建议我们做一期节目，听听你们办公室的故事，或许能为你们的职场困惑提供一些建议。于是我们请大家写信给我们，分享你们的职场建议问题，结果我们在短短一周内收到了超过1500封邮件。我知道，这太疯狂了。所以，我们要开始行动，看看能如何帮助你们解决问题。
We cannot promise we're going to have all the answers but we will try. We'll definitely chat about it though. I do have a question before we get started, Angela. Okay. How are you in general about giving advice? Do you give people advice? It makes me very uncomfortable. I see.
我们不能保证能给出所有答案，但我们会尽力。我们肯定会聊聊这些问题。在开始之前，安吉拉，我有个问题。好的。你通常如何看待给别人建议？你会给别人建议吗？这让我感到非常不自在。我明白了。
I knew this about you. It makes me very nervous. Unless I've known you a really long time, like if you're a very close friend or family, and then I know you, you know? Yes. But if I don't know you, I can't nervous that I'm going to lead you astray. Yeah. So I have some, I'm nervous-sided, I guess you could say, about today.
我了解你这一点。这让我非常紧张。除非我认识你很久了，比如你是非常亲密的朋友或家人，那样我才了解你，对吧？是的。但如果我不了解你，我就不能……我很紧张，怕会把你带偏。是的。所以，我想你可以说，对于今天，我有点紧张。
All right. Jenna, what about you? I don't like to give unsolicited advice, because I don't necessarily like to receive it. Sometimes it's conversation, you know, like I'll tell someone I'm gluten-free and they might recommend a product to me and I like that. I don't see that as unsolicited advice, but I will tell you I do enjoy giving advice.
好吧。詹娜，你呢？我不喜欢主动提供建议，因为我本人也不一定喜欢接受建议。有时候这只是对话，你知道，比如我会告诉别人我不吃麸质，他们可能会向我推荐某种产品，我喜欢这样。我不认为这是主动提供的建议，但我会告诉你，我确实喜欢给别人建议。
I don't mind it. I love to dig in with a person and offer ideas. You know, I love to break down my own life and strategize and stuff. So I kind of like it. I will say this. I like to problem solve. Sure. That's what I'm saying. I guess. So maybe that part of me will open up and doing this podcast. That's right. Well, Jenna, Sam Cassie, before we start opening up these letters from folks, I thought you might be curious to know the top 10 office gripes that I found online. Oh, yeah. Maybe we'll get letters about this. Okay, this is like a little bit of preparation. Ready?
我不介意。我喜欢深入了解一个人并提供想法。你知道，我喜欢剖析自己的生活并制定策略之类的。所以我有点喜欢这样做。我得说，我喜欢解决问题。当然。这就是我想说的。所以也许我性格中的那一部分会在做这个播客时展现出来。没错。好吧，詹娜，在开始拆开这些读者的来信之前，我想你可能会好奇想知道我在网上找到的十大办公室抱怨。哦，是的。也许我们会收到关于这些的信。好吧，这就像一点准备工作。准备好了吗？
Yes. Number one, IT issues. Okay. I'm not going to be able to help anybody with that problem. I know. Number two, computers being slow, which would not be IT issues. We don't know. We're not sure.
是的。第一名，IT问题。好吧。我可帮不了任何人解决那个问题。我知道。第二名，电脑运行缓慢，这可能不属于IT问题。我们不知道。我们不确定。
Number three, people speaking loudly. I know we have some letters about that. Number four, people who have conversations right behind your desk. These feel similar. Don't they? I'm also like, wait, then you're overhearing them. Are they speaking loud?
第三名，人们大声说话。我知道我们有一些关于这个的信。第四名，在你的办公桌后面聊天的人。这感觉很相似，不是吗？我也在想，等等，那你不是在偷听吗？他们说话声音很大吗？
Number five, people who leave dirty dishes in the work sink. Wow. We know how Pam feels about people not cleaning the kitchen. Mm-hmm. Number six, when someone calls in sick, when you know they aren't sick. Yes. Number seven, I didn't see this one coming.
第五名，把脏碗碟留在办公室水槽里的人。哇。我们知道帕姆对人们不打扫厨房有什么感觉。嗯哼。第六名，当你知道某人没生病却请病假时。是的。第七名，我没预料到这个。
Are you ready? Okay. Smelly toilets. Oh. I know. Number eight, printers breaking down, which again, I think could go under IT issues. Number nine, coming into work when you are sick. Oh, so there's people that are like, don't fake it, but don't also bring your germs to work. And then number 10, people who take things from your desk without asking. This happens to receptionists all the time. As a person who was a real receptionist,
准备好了吗？好的。厕所有异味。哦。我知道。第八名，打印机坏了，这再次让我想起，我认为这可能属于IT问题。第九名，生病时还来上班。哦，所以有些人是这样的，别装病，但也别把病菌带到办公室。第十名，不问自取拿走你桌上东西的人。这在接待员身上经常发生。作为一个曾经的真正接待员，
people they come by and they take your pens, they take your stapler, they take a piece of paper, and they don't bring them back. Well, when I was looking this up online, Jenna, there is a lot of chatter out there about workplace etiquette. Well, like I told you, Angela, we got 1500 letters in one week. Well, then we've got a lot of work to do, Jenna.
人们走过来拿走你的笔，拿走你的订书机，拿走一张纸，然后就不还回来了。嗯，当我上网查这个的时候，詹娜，网上有很多关于职场礼仪的讨论。嗯，就像我告诉你的，安吉拉，我们一周内收到了1500封信。好吧，那我们有很多工作要做，詹娜。
Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to get to it. Let's do it. We are back and I'm going to share our very first letter on Dear Office Ladies. I loved this letter. I cracked up. I was so tickles. Oh my gosh. Okay.
我们休息一下吧？回来后，我们要开始处理这些信件了。开始吧。我们回来了，我要分享《亲爱的办公室女士》的第一封信。我喜欢这封信。我笑喷了。我被逗乐了。天哪。好的。
Now, some of you have let us know to not use your full name. So, this is from T in Minneapolis. Dear office ladies, I work downtown and our company has recently moved into a new building. There's an extremely long hallway, maybe 150 feet, that is a buffer between the bullpen and the elevator banks. I need to pause in her letter for one second.
现在，你们有些人告诉我们不要使用全名。所以，这封信来自明尼阿波利斯的T。亲爱的办公室女士，我在市中心工作，我们公司最近搬进了一栋新大楼。有一个非常长的走廊，大约150英尺，是办公区和电梯间之间的缓冲区。我需要暂停一下她的信。
Okay. I went on this website where you can get a visual cue for how long something is or how far or how wide, right? Okay. I love it. The website I went to is called measuringlead.com. Okay. So for you folks that need a visual cue, like I do, 150 feet is about the length of two and a half bowling alleys.
好的。我上了一个网站，在那里你可以直观地看到某样东西有多长、多远或多宽，对吧？好的。我喜欢这个。我去的网站叫measuringlead.com。好的。所以对于像我一样需要视觉提示的朋友们，150英尺大约是两个半保龄球道的长度。
Wow, okay, this is a very long hallway. Yes, and T has to walk down this hallway because that is where the restrooms are. T said while using said hallway, I encounter people walking in the opposite direction, but they're so far away, I can't figure out how many strides away I should be before I acknowledge them. Do I shout my greetings? The second I see them, it's a conundrum. From yours truly, a socially awkward person. T, I felt this.
哇，好吧，这是一个非常长的走廊。是的，T必须走过这个走廊，因为洗手间在那里。T说，在使用该走廊时，我会遇到迎面走来的人，但他们离得太远了，我不知道在打招呼之前应该保持多少步的距离。我应该在我看到他们的那一刻就大声问候吗？这真是一个难题。来自你真诚的，一个社交尴尬的人。T，我感同身受。
Oh, man, did I feel this? I feel like this happens to me sometimes. At drop off and pick up it. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Right? You see people from so far away. sometimes, drop off and pick up it. Oh yeah, yeah. Right, you see people from so far away. And when do you do the knot and the wave? When do you do it?
哦，天哪，我感同身受吗？我觉得这种情况有时会发生在我身上。在接送孩子的时候。哦，是的。是的。对吧？你从很远的地方看到人。有时候，接送孩子的时候。哦，是的，是的。对吧？你从很远的地方看到人。你什么时候点头和挥手？你什么时候做这个动作？
Yeah. I have a trick for this. Oh, let's hear it. I call it the hang nail trick. Hang nail. You can also use your phone, but if you don't have your phone, do you fidget and look at your fingers? Yes.
是的。我有一个诀窍。哦，说来听听。我称之为“倒刺诀窍”。倒刺。你也可以用手机，但如果你没有手机，你会摆弄并看着你的手指吗？是的。
I pretend like I have a hang nail. I'm investigating so I can look down at my hands until I can feel that I'm closer. And then you look up and then you ignore. So that way you don't get like the awkward eye contact from too far away. And then you have to like continue the eye contact all the way down the bowling alley. Yes. How long do I keep eye contact? Right.
我假装我有倒刺。我正在检查，这样我就可以低头看着我的手，直到我觉得我离得更近了。然后你抬头，然后你忽略。这样你就不会因为离得太远而产生尴尬的眼神交流。然后你不得不一直保持眼神交流，直到走完整个保龄球道。是的。我应该保持多久的眼神交流？对吧。
So one, I would say, carry your phone with you because then you can be absorbed in something. If you don't have your phone, check your hang-nail. Yeah. Basically have an item of business. Yes, that gets you down the hallway to avoid this conundrum. So then when you pass them, when you just pass them right at the moment and just say, Hi, hey!
所以第一，我会说，随身携带手机，因为这样你可以沉浸在某件事中。如果你没有手机，检查你的倒刺。是的。基本上找点事做。是的，这能让你走过走廊，避免这个难题。所以当你经过他们时，就在那一刻经过他们，然后说，嗨，嘿！
Hey, yeah. Yeah. What do you think? I really like this. I think I really, I am so bad at this. I often wave the minute I see someone. No, this is you. It's instinctual.
嘿，是的。是的。你觉得怎么样？我真的很喜欢这个。我觉得我真的很不擅长这个。我经常一看到人就挥手。不，这是你。这是本能。
Yeah. I see you. I see you. I'm waving. No, this is you. It's instinctual. Yeah. I see you. I'm waving. I'm waving. Yeah. So I would wave way at the beginning. Yep. And then I feel no pressure.
是的。我看到你了。我看到你了。我在挥手。不，这是你。这是本能。是的。我看到你了。我在挥手。我在挥手。是的。所以我会在很远的时候就挥手。是的。然后我就没有压力了。
And then when I get right near you, I'd be like, hey, so this wouldn't cause you anxiety. This long hallway. Not if I get my wave in at the top. I see. It's like, I got you. I got you. Now I can just be in my own skin. That's another
然后当我走到你身边时，我会说，嘿，所以这不会引起你的焦虑。这个长走廊。如果我在最开始就挥手了，就不会。我明白了。就像是，我看到你了。我看到你了。现在我可以做回我自己了。这是另一个
solution. Yeah. Sometimes I've done that and the person has not weighed back from afar. Oh, then I do get in my head. This is when you get your hang nail. This is when I'm going to look at my fingers. Tea, thank you for writing us. We hope that that helps. Yes. Item of business are just waved right at the top. Our next question is from JC in Indiana. Here's what JC had to say. My office bathroom is small, but it has a small couch in it. Lately, when I've wanted to use the restroom, our office receptionist is on the couch, on the phone, texting or otherwise relaxing. My question is, who wants to relax in an office bathroom? Has anyone else experienced this?
解决方案。是的。有时我这样做，但对方并没有从远处挥手回应。哦，那我就开始胡思乱想了。这就是你该检查倒刺的时候。这就是我要看我手指的时候。T，谢谢你写信给我们。我们希望这能有所帮助。是的。找点事做，或者就在最开始挥手。我们的下一个问题来自印第安纳州的JC。JC是这么说的。我的办公室洗手间很小，但里面有一个小沙发。最近，当我想用洗手间时，我们的办公室接待员就在沙发上，打电话、发短信或以其他方式放松。我的问题是，谁想在办公室洗手间里放松？还有其他人经历过这种情况吗？
I find the interaction awkward at best given I am not there to relax on the couch help. Well, G.C. might remember that a certain someone at Dundermifflant spent some time on a couch in the woman's restroom. Creed. couch in the woman's restroom? CREED! CREED! It was so, even though we were just like pretending it was still so awkward, just the idea of having someone lounge in the restroom because when you got to go, you need no one out there, you know? Yeah, I mean, yes, I would have a very hard time tinkling, doing any business. Yeah, I mean, I get what do you call it? Peefright.
鉴于我不是去沙发上放松的，我觉得这种互动充其量是尴尬的。救命。嗯，JC可能记得邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的某个人在女洗手间的沙发上待过一段时间。克里德。女洗手间的沙发？克里德！克里德！这太……即使我们只是在演戏，这仍然非常尴尬，仅仅是有人在洗手间里闲逛的想法，因为当你需要去的时候，你需要那里没人，你知道吗？是的，我的意思是，是的，我会很难小便，做任何事情。是的，我的意思是，我得了所谓的……尿怯症。
You get nervous, Pee. A little bit. So, you know, sometimes what I do is I do that flush and go. You flush and pee at the same time. Yeah, because- Doesn't that splash your butt? No. Are you up for a while?
你会紧张，尿不出来。一点点。所以，你知道，有时我做的是那种冲水然后离开。你一边冲水一边小便。是的，因为……那不会溅到你的屁股吗？不会。你站着有一会儿了吗？
Because it's going down. It's going down. No, I'll tell you something I don't do. Some have a kickback, though. What? I do not hover or squat over a toilet seat. I find the whole practice very annoying because the people who do spray the seat, and most of the time they don't clean it up. I really got upset about this when I was pregnant because you know when you definitely can't hover,
因为它正在流下去。它正在流下去。不，我告诉你一件我不做的事。有些人会后仰。什么？我不会悬空或蹲在马桶座圈上。我觉得整个做法非常烦人，因为那些这样做的人会把座圈弄脏，而且大多数时候他们不清理。我怀孕时对此真的很生气，因为你知道当你绝对不能悬空时，
when you've got a giant preggers belly, I got to sit down and go, but first I'm cleaning up someone else's spray. Everyone just sit down. Here's my situation. You know the liner things that you get there. Yeah, the liner thing. My stream isn't strong enough to get the flap out of the way, so then the flap of the liner can come back, not happening, not into it.
当你有一个巨大的孕肚时，我必须坐下来解决，但首先我得清理别人的喷溅物。大家都坐下来吧。这是我的情况。你知道那里提供的垫纸吗？是的，那种垫纸。我的尿流不够强，无法把垫纸的活页冲走，所以活页可能会反弹回来，不行，我不喜欢那样。
So I do two little strips of toilet paper and I make my own little seat. We're off top. We have gone off top. We have gone off top. We're sorry. Okay. One moment.
所以我用两小条卫生纸，自己做一个小座垫。我们跑题了。我们跑题了。我们跑题了。我们很抱歉。好的。等一下。
Okay. To the letter. Here's the thing. JC, I don't know why the receptionist is in there texting and on the phone and all that. My guess is maybe there's no break room, nowhere for her to go to just be off the clock, so to speak. That was my first question.
好的。回到信件。事情是这样的。JC，我不知道为什么接待员在里面发短信、打电话之类的。我的猜测是，也许没有休息室，她没地方去，没法下班，可以这么说。这是我的第一个问题。
If that's not true, JC, if there is a break room, this is what I think you should do. I think maybe you get the keys to the office on a Saturday morning, whenever someone's not there, hear me out. Jerry Alapamist, you know, is giving me such a look. You get rid of the sofa. Get it out of there. This is nowhere it moves. Well, then there's nowhere to sit and hang out.
如果不是这样，JC，如果真的有休息室，我觉得你应该这样做。我想也许你可以在周六早上，没人的时候去拿办公室钥匙，听我说完。杰瑞·阿拉帕米斯特，你知道，他看我的眼神都不对了。把沙发处理掉。把它搬走。这地方根本没法移动。好吧，那这样就没地方坐着闲聊了。
It becomes a non-hangout zone. So your solution is get rid of the couch. Yeah, or you could, you know, be an adult and just talk to the receptionist and say, hey, when you're in here, I can't go go because you're in here and it's awkward. Yeah. I mean, Jay-C, you're probably not the only person
它就变成了一个非闲聊区。所以你的解决方案是把沙发扔了。是的，或者你可以，你知道，表现得像个成年人，直接跟前台说，嘿，你在里面的时候，我没法进去，因为你在里面，这很尴尬。是的。我的意思是，JC，你可能不是唯一一个
that is having this problem. You would be the hero of the office. You could just confront it head on. Or I suppose break into the office after hours and remove the couch. These are the two options. But I'm with you. It's odd.
遇到这个问题的人。你会成为办公室的英雄。你可以直接面对它。或者我想你可以下班后潜入办公室把沙发搬走。这是两个选择。但我同意你的看法。这很奇怪。
Who wants to be in there? Nobody. It's not a hangout zone. It's not a hangout zone. Everyone stop hanging out in your bathrooms. I mean, listen, sometimes you do go to the bathroom and get chatty, you know, with other people. What?
谁想待在里面？没人想。那不是闲聊区。那不是闲聊区。大家都别在厕所里闲聊了。我的意思是，听着，有时候你确实会去厕所然后跟别人聊起来，你知道的。什么？
I mean, I feel like if you and I were like, we went to a ladies room, we might have a combo where we're washing our hands. That is not what we're talking about here. I know, it's sofa hangout. No sofa hangout. no sofa hangout. Don't hang out on a sofa in a bathroom. That's what I'm saying.
我的意思是，我觉得如果我们俩去女厕所，我们可能会在洗手的时候聊几句。我们说的不是这个。我知道，这是沙发闲聊。不要沙发闲聊。不要沙发闲聊。别在厕所的沙发上闲聊。这就是我想说的。
It's a non-sofahang. Yeah. Non-sofahang. It's a non-sofahang zone. Maybe put a sign up. Non-sofahs. If you put a sofa in there, someone's gonna sit on it. I've come around, Angela lose the sofa.
这是一个非沙发闲聊区。是的。非沙发闲聊。这是一个非沙发闲聊区。也许贴个告示。禁止沙发。如果你在里面放个沙发，肯定会有人坐。我改变主意了，安吉拉，把沙发撤了吧。
Thank you. Our next letter is from AR in Syracuse. AR says, how do I tell a coworker to take private calls, not on speaker phone? This person frequently is talking to banks, doctors, their mom about very specific personal matters while I'm trying to work and it makes it difficult to focus. I know way too much about their personal life because they're always on speaker phone.
谢谢。下一封信来自雪城（Syracuse）的AR。AR说，我该怎么告诉同事接私人电话时不要开免提？这个人经常在我要工作的时候，开着免提跟银行、医生、还有他妈妈谈论非常具体的私事，这让我很难集中注意力。我知道太多关于他私生活的事情了，因为他总是开着免提。
Also, this person happens to be my supervisor. Please help. Oh boy. Oh boy. This would drive me crazy. This is very Michael Scott. Yes. This is a little bit of a pet peeve of mine.
而且，这个人正好是我的主管。请帮帮我。天哪。天哪。这会把我逼疯的。这太迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）了。是的。这有点让我抓狂。
Mm hmm. The speaker phone talking. Yeah. Well, you might want to be careful then when you call my mom. Because my mom now, she used to not. But now, you know, every conversation she has is on speaker phone. Every time I call her, it doesn't matter where she is, I'm on speaker phone. Okay, here's the thing.
嗯哼。开免提说话。是的。好吧，那你给我也妈打电话时可要小心了。因为我妈现在，她以前不这样。但现在，你知道，她每次通话都开免提。每次我给她打电话，不管她在哪里，我都在免提里。好吧，是这样的。
I think when you get older, it's easier to hear on speaker phone. Yes. I've noticed this. I'll see elderly people that are like, hold on a second, I got to switch you to speaker phone, because the sound is better. And also there are people with hearing impairments who need to be on speaker phone. But that's it. Everyone else.
我觉得人老了以后，开免提听起来更容易。是的。我注意到了。我会看到老年人说，等一下，我得把你切换到免提，因为声音更清楚。而且还有些听力障碍的人需要开免提。但仅此而已。其他人。
Everyone else, stop it. Lock it down. Yes. I'm pretty sure that the 40-year-old business guy that I saw in Starbucks the other day did not need to have his call on speaker phone. We get it. We get it. Doing important business.
其他人，别这样。关掉它。是的。我很确定我前几天在星巴克看到的那个40岁的商务男士不需要开免提打电话。我们懂了。我们懂了。在谈重要生意。
Now we all know. Shut it down. Well, I was curious what the internet said about this type of etiquette and according to a website called the Dapper Diplomat, here are six situations where using a speaker phone is not okay. Is one of them funerals. Oh, no.
现在我们都知道了。关掉它。嗯，我很好奇互联网上关于这种礼仪是怎么说的，根据一个叫“Dapper Diplomat”的网站，以下是六种不适合使用免提的情况。其中一个是葬礼吗？哦，不。
What? Oh my gosh, I hope not. You'd be surprised at the things people do. That's true. All right, what are the things people do. That's true. All right, what are the six that they say? Airport lounge. Yes. Okay.
什么？天哪，我希望不是。你会惊讶于人们做出的事情。那是真的。好吧，人们会做哪些事。那是真的。好吧，他们说的六种情况是什么？机场休息室。是的。好的。
Client meeting. Of course. Restaurant. Yes. My mom talks me on speakerphone at restaurants. I love you, mom. I love you. Your mom gets a pass.
客户会议。当然。餐厅。是的。我妈在餐厅跟我通话时就开免提。我爱你，妈妈。我爱你。你妈妈可以例外。
We've already established that. Yes, but I need to remember. Now whenever I call you, Mom. I love you. Your mom gets a pass. We've heard you've established that. Yes, but I need to remember. Now whenever I call her, I just say, where you at, Mom? First thing we say. Where am I on speakerphone? Exactly. That's my message. That's what your mom's text is.
我们已经达成共识了。是的，但我得记住。现在每当我给你打电话，妈妈。我爱你。你妈妈可以例外。我们已经听过你达成共识了。是的，但我得记住。现在每当我给她打电话，我就说，妈，你在哪儿？我们说的第一句话。我是在免提里吗？没错。这就是我的信息。这就是你妈妈发的信息。
Next one is, Dr's office. Yeah. No speakerphone at the doctor's office. Restroom? Okay. Yeah. Right? And the checkout line. Yeah. I agree with that list. I do too. I have some advice for AR
下一个是，医生办公室。是的。在医生办公室不能开免提。洗手间？好的。对吧？还有结账排队时。是的，我同意这个清单。我也同意。我给AR一些建议。
Okay, and Syracuse with this problem You know sometimes people have a hard time recognizing their behavior Until they see it like mirrored back to them. So maybe AR can get a friend, and they can stage like a highly personal private overshare conversation on speakerphone. In the proximity of this person who is always talking on speakerphone, maybe they'll like see it and get it and have an epiphany.
好的，雪城的AR，关于这个问题。你知道有时候人们很难意识到自己的行为，直到他们看到别人也这样做。所以也许AR可以找个朋友，在那个总是开免提的人附近，上演一场非常私人的、过度分享的免提对话，也许他们会看到并明白，然后恍然大悟。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, because I see how it's like, I don't think you can say, hey, can you stop taking all those calls on speakerphone? Right? Yeah. You can't directly say it. This is this person's supervisor. Yes. So there's that. Here's what I was going to suggest. Okay. The next time AR, you are speaking with your supervisor, I would ask about one of the very personal things you overheard. Yes, I would say, did you get that rash cleared up? Or whatever it is? Yeah, yeah. Another thing you could do is you could
嗯哼。是的，因为我明白这有多难，我觉得你不能直接说，嘿，你能别再开免提接那些电话了吗？对吧？是的。你不能直接说。这是这个人的主管。是的。所以就是这样。这是我建议的。好的。下次AR，当你和你的主管谈话时，我会问起你无意中听到的那些非常私人的事情之一。是的，我会说，你的皮疹治好了吗？或者类似的事情？是的，是的。你还可以做另一件事，就是
try the like the triangulate method where you go to your supervisor and you say there's a coworker who has taken a few personal calls on speaker phone and I feel a little uncomfortable about it and I just didn't know, like, is there a way maybe you would write like a general email to the group? No, you think they're gonna know immediately? No, I think you have Pam Brain right now from years of playing Pam. This is how Pam would play Kate Michael, but it would always blow up in her face.
尝试那种三角测量法，你去找你的主管说，有个同事接私人电话时总是开免提，我觉得有点不舒服，我不知道，有没有可能你给小组写一封通用的邮件？不，你觉得他们会立刻知道吗？不，我觉得你现在有“帕姆大脑”（Pam Brain），因为演了这么多年的帕姆。这就是帕姆会怎么对付迈克尔，但总是会搞砸。
No, then the boss is like, we need to have a meeting. Everyone. I don't know. I don't know. But I like your idea of mirroring. And then I like my idea of just like lean into it and be like, hey, how is the Toe fungus? Did you finally get that cleared up? Two ways to go.
不，然后老板会说，我们需要开个会。所有人。我不知道。我不知道。但我喜欢你那个镜像模仿的主意。然后我喜欢我的主意，就是顺着话说，嘿，脚气怎么样了？终于治好了吗？有两种方式。
Mm-hmm. Well listen, I think we should take a break. When we come back, we have a serious parking situation to discuss. Yes, we do. We are back and our next letter is from CW in Minnesota. CW says this, since the pandemic started, I have been working from home, but my office recently announced that we are now required to come in two days a week. I would not be mad about this,
嗯哼。好吧，听着，我觉得我们该休息一下了。回来后，我们要讨论一个严重的停车问题。是的，我们要讨论。我们回来了，下一封信来自明尼苏达州的CW。CW说，自从疫情开始，我就一直在家办公，但我的办公室最近宣布，我们现在被要求每周去办公室两天。我本来不会对此感到生气，
but they make us pay for parking. What? Yeah. And get this. The company owns the parking lot. No. Yes. Come on. It still makes the employees pay to park. It costs $10 a day. That's BS. That is over $1,000 a year. CW, I would be ticked off. Yes, there's more. The parking ramp isn't even big enough for all the employees, so some people have to park further away and walk 15 minutes to the office. See Kevin and Chair model for my feelings on this.
但他们让我们付停车费。什么？是的。而且你听着。公司拥有那个停车场。不。是的。得了吧。它还让员工付停车费。每天要10美元。这太扯了。那一年要超过1000美元。CW，我会气炸的。是的，还有更多。停车坡道甚至大到装不下所有员工，所以有些人不得不停在更远的地方，走15分钟才能到办公室。看看凯文和椅子模特（Chair model）就知道我的感受了。
Yes. This is crazy, right? I should not have to pay to go to work. Agree. I'm with C feelings on this. Yes. This is crazy, right? I should not have to pay to go to work. Agree. I'm with CW on this. I think that's a load of crap. I mean, you're basically taking a thousand dollars out of your salary to park. That is BS. Do you want to hear something? Do you want to hear why I connected with this question? Yeah. This happened to me. I was working as an executive assistant in this big office building in downtown Los Angeles. It had a parking garage, but the company would only pay for the parking spaces of the executives.
是的。这太疯狂了，对吧？我不应该为了去上班而付钱。同意。我同意CW的感受。是的。这太疯狂了，对吧？我不应该为了去上班而付钱。同意。我同意CW的看法。我觉得这简直是胡扯。我的意思是，你基本上是从工资里扣掉一千美元来停车。这太扯了。你想听点什么吗？你想听听我为什么会对这个问题产生共鸣吗？是的。这发生在我身上。我曾在洛杉矶市中心的一栋大办公楼里担任行政助理。它有一个停车库，但公司只为高管支付停车位。
It was part of their salary package. I was an hourly worker. I didn't have a salary package. It didn't include parking. I had to park in a pay lot, several blocks away, and walk probably 10 or 15 minutes. So one time when my boss was going to go on vacation, I asked if I could use his parking space while he was gone. I said, would you mind if I used your parking card and I parked in your space? And he was like, well, don't you already park here? And I said, no, I don't park here. I park down on 5th Street minutes away. Yeah. He was like, what? To his credit, when he found out that I did not get to park in the building,
这是他们薪酬方案的一部分。我是小时工。我没有薪酬方案。它不包括停车。我不得不停在一个收费停车场，在几个街区外，走大概10或15分钟。所以有一次我老板要去度假，我问他我能不能在他不在的时候用他的停车位。我说，如果你不介意的话，我能用你的停车卡停在你的车位吗？他说，你不是已经停在这里了吗？我说，不，我不停在这里。我停在几分钟外的第五街。是的。他说，什么？值得称赞的是，当他发现我不能在楼里停车时，
he made the company give me a parking space. They changed the policy. That's great. Because he was amazing. This guy was amazing. Like good boss. Yeah, you just didn't know. Well, clearly this company knows. Well, yeah. Well, I will tell you this. I was working years ago at a company and they had parking for us in the building and then it was bought out by another company and they got rid of our parking. Same thing. execs had parking. The rest of us, and they got rid of our parking. Same thing, execs had parking, the rest of us. They paid Sears Department Store, which was three blocks away for parking for us.
他让公司给了我一个停车位。他们改变了政策。那太棒了。因为他太棒了。这家伙太棒了。真是个好老板。是的，你只是不知道。好吧，显然这家公司知道。好吧，是的。好吧，我会告诉你这个。我多年前在一家公司工作，他们在大楼里为我们提供停车位，然后被另一家公司收购了，他们取消了我们的停车位。同样的事情。高管有停车位。我们其他人，他们取消了我们的停车位。同样的事情，高管有停车位，我们其他人。他们为我们支付了三个街区外的西尔斯百货（Sears Department Store）的停车费。
So we had to now start parking at the Sears Department Store and walk three blocks, and it was hot, and like you would carry your lunch and all your things, and one time... Don't leave anything in your car. I'll tell you that. Don't leave anything in your car, I'll tell you that. Don't leave anything in your car. And then here's the other thing.
所以我们现在不得不开始停在西尔斯百货，走三个街区，而且天气很热，你还得带着午餐和所有东西，有一次……别把任何东西留在车里。我告诉你。别把任何东西留在车里，我告诉你。别把任何东西留在车里。然后还有另一件事。
Some days Sears was busy. And I was like, where are we parking? Then Sears would put everyone with our company sticker and they're back lot. Oh boy. Do you see what I'm saying? I do. So then I had to start factoring in all this extra time
有些日子西尔斯很忙。我就想，我们停哪儿？然后西尔斯会把所有贴有我们公司标签的车都停在他们的后停车场。天哪。你明白我的意思吗？我明白。所以我不得不开始把所有这些额外的时间考虑进去
to get to work so that I could figure out is it gonna be a busy day? It's sears or not. Yeah, you're tracking. Are they having things on sales? Yeah, Memorial Day sale. No. Oh dear. Forget it. So then one day it made, I'm telling you, this parking lot thing made me into a grumpier person when I would show up to work. One day I walk in and I'm waiting for the elevator to go up to the office. And my manager, my boss was there. He wasn't the boss boss, just my manager. He started talking to me about this new script that we would have to say as operators. And it was 15 minutes before I clocked in. Because we actually clocked in, right? And I turned to him and I said, I don't work for you yet. Oh my gosh.
去上班，这样我才能弄清楚今天会不会是忙碌的一天？是西尔斯还是别的。是的，你在追踪。他们有促销活动吗？是的，阵亡将士纪念日大甩卖。不。哦，天哪。算了吧。所以有一天，我告诉你，这个停车场的事情让我在去上班时变得更暴躁了。有一天我走进去，等着电梯上楼去办公室。我的经理，我的老板在那里。他不是大老板，只是我的经理。他开始跟我谈论我们作为接线员必须说的新脚本。那是在我打卡上班前15分钟。因为我们确实要打卡，对吧？我转向他说，我还没为你工作呢。天哪。
That is not you. It is not me. You are a friendly person. I'm a friendly person. But I broke you. This broke me. I was so frustrated and annoyed, and this was a job where it was like,
那不是你。那不是我。你是个友好的人。我是个友好的人。但我被击垮了。这击垮了我。我感到非常沮丧和恼火，而且这是一份本来就……
not a great job anyway. And I was just like, oh my gosh. His eyes got so big. I said, if you want to talk to me about this, you can talk to me at 10 a.m. After the, yeah, after you clock in, you know what? You're really pointing at something here, Angela, which is that this is how CW is starting these days. W is starting these days. Dilling what? Where is that meant?
不是什么好工作。我当时就想，天哪。他的眼睛瞪得好大。我说，如果你想跟我谈这个，你可以在上午10点跟我谈。打卡之后，你知道吗？安吉拉，你真的指出了重点，那就是CW现在就是这样开始的。CW现在就是这样开始的。在说什么？那是什么意思？
Yes, feeling like the company doesn't value them. Exactly. That's not good office policy. No. And I think, honestly, CW, I think you should complain about it. I think that you should talk to some of your fellow employees and I think you should take it to the appropriate person at your office because you should not have to pay for this parking, especially since they own the lot.
是的，感觉公司不重视他们。没错。那不是好的办公室政策。不。而且老实说，CW，我觉得你应该投诉这件事。我觉得你应该和你的同事谈谈，并且你应该把它反映给办公室里合适的人，因为你不应该为这个停车位付费，尤其是因为停车场是他们自己的。
Exactly, they own the lot. And I think CW is wrong. It's wrong. And I think you should bring up that basically you're making, you say here, over $1,000 less a year. And that's not right. Not right. Oh, wow.
没错，停车场是他们自己的。我觉得CW是对的。这不对。而且我觉得你应该提出来，基本上你赚的钱，正如你这里所说，每年少了1000多美元。这不对。不对。哦，哇。
I know. We got fired up. We got fired up about that one. Hot to trot. About that one. Hot to trot. Coming in wide open. That's right. What do you got, Angela? You have got a question for us. I sure do. All right. I'm very excited about this question. I just want you to know I felt seen. Okay. I want you to know that. I just want you to know I felt seen. Okay, I want you to know that. Our next question is from VC in British Columbia. VC writes in and says, I wanted to share something I have recently started to do at work,
我知道。我们很激动。我们对那件事很激动。跃跃欲试。关于那件事。跃跃欲试。全速前进。没错。你有什么，安吉拉？你有一个问题要问我们。我当然有。好的。我对这个问题感到非常兴奋。我只是想让你知道我感到被看见了。好的。我想让你知道这一点。我只是想让你知道我感到被看见了。好的，我想让你知道这一点。我们的下一个问题来自不列颠哥伦比亚省的VC。VC写信说，我想分享一些我最近在工作中开始做的事情，
which was a game changer. A game changer? All right. I save all the different sauce packets from my co-workers take out. I'm now the sauce lady. and I feel irreplaceable. Anyone need sauce? They go through me first. I don't know how to respond.
这改变了游戏规则。改变游戏规则？好的。我保存了同事外卖里的所有不同酱料包。我现在是酱料女士。我觉得自己不可替代。有人需要酱料吗？他们先找我。我不知道该怎么回应。
I am charmed. Uh-huh, by this. I love this, so if I'm at work, let's say. Mm-hmm. And I open my lunch, I'm like, oh my gosh, I forgot soy sauce. I know who to go to, I'm going to V.C, I forgot soy sauce. I know who to go, too. I'm going to VC. Yeah, you are. You're going to the sauce lady.
我被迷住了。嗯哼，被这个。我喜欢这个，所以如果我在工作，比方说。嗯哼。我打开午餐，我想，天哪，我忘了带酱油。我知道该找谁，我要找VC，我忘了带酱油。我知道该找谁。我要找VC。是的，你是。你要去找酱料女士。
I am the sauce lady. Angela is the sauce lady. I want to tell you something. If you get takeout and you don't use your ketchup packet or your soy sauce packet, I'm gonna take it. I know. Don't throw that out. That's wasteful.
我是酱料女士。安吉拉是酱料女士。我想告诉你一件事。如果你点了外卖，而你没有用你的番茄酱包或酱油包，我会拿走它。我知道。别把它扔了。那太浪费了。
You've got a drawer. I have a drawer in my kitchen. Now, my husband and I might have gotten into one or two tips, not arguments, tips about the sauce packet drawer. Do we really need all these sauces? That's what I get. Guess what? Tell me.
你有一个抽屉。我的厨房里有一个抽屉。现在，我和我丈夫可能因为酱料包抽屉发生过一两次小争执，不是大吵，是小争执。我们真的需要所有这些酱料吗？这就是我得到的。你猜怎么着？告诉我。
Did it pay off? It's paid off. Like, all of a sudden, you can't get sriracha? People are like, I don't know. I don't know why people are hoarding sriracha. Guess who has a ton of Aracha packets? You, this lady. Also, let's say the kids have a field trip.
值得吗？值得。就像，突然之间，你买不到是拉差辣椒酱了？人们会说，我不知道。我不知道为什么人们在囤积是拉差。你猜谁有一大堆是拉差包？你，这位女士。另外，比方说孩子们要去实地考察。
You gotta pack them a sack lunch. Mm-hmm. Someone wants ketchup. I gotta sauce packet. Someone wants ketchup. Yeah, you do. It's not going in a tiny Tupperware. Oh no.
你得给他们打包午餐。嗯哼。有人想要番茄酱。我有一个酱料包。有人想要番茄酱。是的，你有。它不会装在小特百惠盒子里。哦，不。
Oh, you got a packet. Who wants to squirt ketchup into a tupperware. You want a packet. Guess what else? What, tell me. You want salt and pepper? Oh no, it goes beyond sauces. Yes, I say we're into spices.
哦，你有一个包。谁想把番茄酱挤进特百惠盒子里。你想要一个包。你猜还有什么？什么，告诉我。你想要盐和胡椒？哦，不，这不仅仅是酱料。是的，我说我们进入了调味品领域。
That's right, I saved the little salt and pepper packets. You want to go somewhere, you want a little bit of salt? Don't want to put it in a zip lock. I got a little packet for you. Let me ask you this question. Would you happen to have a utensil pack with a napkin wrapped in a little bit of plastic? You bet your buns, I do.
没错，我保存了小盐和胡椒包。你想去某个地方，想要一点盐？不想把它放在密封袋里。我有一个小包给你。让我问你这个问题。你会有那种带餐巾纸的餐具包，用一点塑料包着吗？你敢打赌，我有。
You want to know in the back of the sauce packet drawer is a whole bunch of ready to go. You tinsel. Are there some chopsticks in there too? I tell you. Wow. I'm ready. I love the sauce, lady. You found there too, I bet. Hell yeah. Wow, I'm ready. I love the sauce lady.
你想知道酱料包抽屉后面有一大堆现成的餐具吗。里面还有一些筷子吗？我告诉你。哇。我准备好了。我喜欢酱料女士。我敢打赌你也找到了。当然。哇，我准备好了。我喜欢酱料女士。
You found your people. I did. I'm getting you a shirt that's a sauce lady now. Please do, I will wear it with pride. I will think of VC and British Columbia. It wasn't quite an advice question. It was more of a work share and I loved it. Before we move on, of everything in your sauce drawer,
你找到了你的同类。是的。我要给你买一件写着酱料女士的衬衫。请一定要买，我会自豪地穿上它。我会想到不列颠哥伦比亚省的VC。这不太像是一个建议问题。这更像是一个工作分享，我喜欢它。在我们继续之前，你酱料抽屉里的所有东西，
what can you not do without? Manace. Manace. Yeah. Manace packet. I love mayonnaise, guys. And you know what? I'm not alone.
你不能没有的是什么？蛋黄酱。蛋黄酱。是的。蛋黄酱包。我喜欢蛋黄酱，伙计们。你知道吗？我并不孤单。
Because I looked up. There's so many sauce stats. You didn't know you needed this in your life, you guys. But if you Google most popular sauces, oh my gosh, the data. There's global, like global websites about favorite sauces around the world. I concentrated on the United States, but let me tell you, there's a lot.
因为我查了一下。有太多的酱料统计数据。你们不知道你们生活中需要这个。但如果你谷歌最受欢迎的酱料，天哪，数据。有全球性的，比如关于世界各地最爱酱料的全球网站。我专注于美国，但我告诉你，有很多。
Also, did you know the month of March is the national sauce month? No, that is not a thing. It is a thing. What? And what am I doing in March to celebrate the sauces? Each of your favorite sauces, lady. Here are the most popular sauces in the US.
另外，你知道三月是全国酱料月吗？不，那不是真的。它是真的。什么？我在三月做什么来庆祝酱料？吃你最喜欢的酱料，女士。以下是美国最受欢迎的酱料。
Catch up, rain supreme. 25 states say it's their favorite sauce. Wow. Five states say barbecue sauce. And then eight states had favorites that were the only number one in their entire state. What was it? Okay. Hawaii mayonnaise. Okay. Louisiana Tabasco sauce. New Mexico, vinaigrette, Utah, fry sauce. What is fry sauce? This is the only one I didn't know. I've never heard of fry sauce. Sam Cassie, have you ever heard of fry sauce?
番茄酱，占据统治地位。25个州说它是他们最喜欢的酱料。哇。五个州说是烧烤酱。然后八个州有各自唯一的州内第一名。是什么？好的。夏威夷，蛋黄酱。好的。路易斯安那，塔巴斯科辣酱。新墨西哥，油醋汁，犹他，薯条酱。什么是薯条酱？这是我唯一不知道的。我从来没听说过薯条酱。山姆·卡西，你听说过薯条酱吗？
Nope, you got nothing for you. Got nothing. Okay, South Dakota Ranch. Love me some ranch. That would be number two in my packet list. Vermont, Sriracha, Maine, relish, Rhode Island, cocktail sauce. Huh, no, most popular sauces. What's your favorite sauce?
没有，你什么都不知道。什么都没有。好的，南达科他，牧场沙拉酱。我喜欢牧场沙拉酱。那会是我酱料包列表里的第二名。佛蒙特，是拉差，缅因，调味酱，罗德岛，鸡尾酒酱。嗯，不，最受欢迎的酱料。你最喜欢的酱料是什么？
I'm gonna be honest with you, I'm not a big sauce gal. What? I mean, you eat things dry. I mean, what, things are fine. You don't have to dip everything in another flavor. You know, I enjoy a fry just fried with some salt. I might dip it in some ketchup, but you know what, if there's no ketchup,
老实说，我不是一个喜欢酱料的人。什么？我是说，你吃东西干吃。我是说，什么，东西挺好的。你不必把所有东西都蘸上另一种味道。你知道，我喜欢薯条，只炸过加点盐。我可能会蘸点番茄酱，但你知道吗，如果没有番茄酱，
I'll live and I'll enjoy my fry. That's, that's, well, I don't know how to reconcile that. And you know what I'm not gonna do? I'm not gonna dip my fry in anything but ketchup. I'm not putting it in a mayo. I'm not using ranch on anything. I do enjoy mixing mayo and ketchup and like throwing that maybe on a burger.
我会活下去，我会享受我的薯条。那是，那是，好吧，我不知道该怎么调和这一点。你知道我不会做什么吗？我不会把薯条蘸在除了番茄酱以外的任何东西里。我不会把它放在蛋黄酱里。我不会在任何东西上用牧场沙拉酱。我确实喜欢把蛋黄酱和番茄酱混合，然后把它涂在汉堡上。
Yeah. I also like whatever that thing is that like thousand island dressing with relishing it that we're throwing on the Big Mac. I'm into that or versions of that. That's similar to your male culture. Yeah, so I'm liking those things, but if sauces disappeared,
是的。我也喜欢那种东西，比如千岛酱加调味酱，我们把它涂在巨无霸上。我喜欢那个，或者它的变体。这类似于你的蛋黄酱文化。是的，所以我喜欢那些东西，但如果酱料消失了，
if all the sauces you just listed disappeared, it would be barely a blip for me. Oh, it'd be a sad day for me. Yeah. I love the different tastes in my mouth. That's what she said. That's what she said. Yes, that's what she said. I think that is a great way to complete that question.
如果你刚才列出的所有酱料都消失了，对我来说几乎没什么影响。哦，那对我来说会是悲伤的一天。是的。我喜欢嘴里不同的味道。她就是这么说的。她就是这么说的。是的，她就是这么说的。我认为这是完成那个问题的绝佳方式。
Mm-hmm. I'm gonna get you a shirt that says, Saus Lady on the front and on the back, it's gonna say, I love all the flavors in my mouth. I love all the flavors in my mouth. You best be making me that shirt. All right. This next question is coming from A in Sacramento, California. I am a college senior and will be starting my job hunt soon. I have started the job search, which is both
嗯哼。我要给你买一件衬衫，前面写着酱料女士，后面写着，我喜欢嘴里所有的味道。我喜欢嘴里所有的味道。你最好给我做那件衬衫。好的。下一个问题来自加利福尼亚州萨克拉门托的A。我是一名大学四年级学生，很快就要开始找工作了。我已经开始了求职，这既
exciting and terrifying at the same time. I would love any advice when it comes to interviewing for a full-time job. Thanks for your advice, and I love the show. Well, A, I love this question, because I actually wrote a whole chapter about interviewing in my book, The Actors Life. Because when I first came out to Los Angeles, I would go on a lot of general meetings, which are like interviews. They were not auditions. I wasn't performing. Right. They're just sit down and talk to this producer or director or executive. I was very, very bad at them.
令人兴奋又令人恐惧。在面试全职工作时，我很乐意得到任何建议。谢谢你的建议，我喜欢这个节目。嗯，A，我喜欢这个问题，因为我实际上在我的书《演员的生活》中写了整整一章关于面试的内容。因为当我刚来到洛杉矶时，我会参加很多一般性会议，就像面试一样。它们不是试镜。我没有表演。对。它们只是坐下来和制片人、导演或高管交谈。我非常非常不擅长这些。
Really? I would think you'd be good at them. No, I had to really learn how to be good in interviews. Okay. You know, it is a whole skill. I agree. You can be very good at the job, but very bad at explaining that you're good at the job. Right.
真的吗？我以为你会很擅长。不，我必须真正学习如何擅长面试。好的。你知道，这是一项完整的技能。我同意。你可能非常擅长这份工作，但非常不擅长解释你擅长这份工作。对。
So, this is something that I think you have to take time and preparation with. I agree. All right. So, I had an agent at the time, and despite my terrible interview, he decided to represent me, and then he gave me some coaching. Okay. He had some rules about how to give good interviews, good general meetings, and they're great. I passed along a lot of his advice in my book,
所以，我认为这是你需要花时间和准备的事情。我同意。好的。所以，我当时有一位经纪人，尽管我面试很糟糕，但他还是决定代理我，然后他给了我一些指导。好的。他有一些关于如何进行良好面试、良好一般性会议的规则，它们很棒。我在书中传达了他很多建议，
and here it is. Rule number one, show up on time, and by the way, on time means 10 minutes early. Because you have to remember, you're going to need to find time to park. You're going to have to find the office. You might have to go pee. Yes, yeah, well, we would definitely need to go pee. You wanna account for any unforeseen problems, right? Flat tire, whatever. Be very early. That was his big advice.
这就是。第一条规则，准时到达，顺便说一句，准时意味着提前10分钟。因为你必须记住，你需要时间找停车位。你必须找到办公室。你可能需要去上厕所。是的，是的，好吧，我们肯定需要去上厕所。你要考虑到任何不可预见的问题，对吧？爆胎，什么的。要非常早。那是他最大的建议。
He also said, do not bring a beverage into your interview and turn off your phone. He said, you would not believe how many people come in carrying a Starbucks in their phone dinging. He said, you think you shouldn't have to give this advice, but you do. I think you do, because my phone went in ding, but I almost always show up with the iced tea. Yeah, he says, leave your beverage in your car. Okay. We're not there yet. You know, this is a stranger. Yeah, you don't drink your beverage in an interview. Okay. We're not there yet. You know, this is a stranger. Yeah. You don't drink your beverage in an interview.
他还说，不要带饮料去面试，关掉手机。他说，你不会相信有多少人带着星巴克进来，手机叮当作响。他说，你认为你不应该给出这个建议，但你必须给。我认为你必须给，因为我的手机响了，但我几乎总是带着冰茶出现。是的，他说，把你的饮料留在车里。好的。我们还没到那一步。你知道，这是一个陌生人。是的，你不要在面试中喝饮料。好的。我们还没到那一步。你知道，这是一个陌生人。是的。你不要在面试中喝饮料。
Okay. Okay. Second, remember, you are interviewing them too. An interview is like a first date. You're there to discern whether or not this is a match. It has to be a match for both people. It has to go both ways. And that always brought me some comfort because it made me kind of like less
好的。好的。第二，记住，你也在面试他们。面试就像第一次约会。你在那里是为了辨别这是否合适。这对双方来说都必须合适。它必须是双向的。这总是给我带来一些安慰，因为它让我变得不那么
needy because I was remembering like, hey, I'm here to discern if I like this place too. Right. I have a say in this, I have some worth and I'm going to take agency for myself. Yes. Okay. Third, I think it's always good to be ready with some sort of icebreaker to get some banter going. You don't want to launch into your skills right away. So what is something that could spark a connection? Sometimes I would go in the rooms and I would kind of look around at kind of clock things. Like, oh, where do these people, do they have a vacation photo up? Can that spark a conversation? One time I walked in and this woman had this beautiful blue ring on and I said,
需要别人，因为我记得，嘿，我也在这里辨别我是否喜欢这个地方。对。我对此有发言权，我有价值，我要为自己争取代理权。是的。好的。第三，我认为准备某种破冰船来开始闲聊总是好的。你不想马上开始谈论你的技能。那么有什么可以激发联系的东西呢？有时我会走进房间，我会环顾四周，观察一些事情。比如，哦，这些人把度假照片挂出来了吗？那能引发对话吗？有一次我走进去，这个女人戴着这枚漂亮的蓝色戒指，我说，
oh my goodness, I love your ring. And she said, oh, it's an aquamarine, I'm a March baby. And I said, I'm a March baby. And then we had a little bonding moment about both being Pisces. I think these little things are very helpful. Because remember, businesses are interested in your skills and your abilities, but they are also going to have to like be around you on a personal level. So, right? This rapport, it's helpful. You know, Greg Daniels once told me that people want to work with people that they think they can spend a 12-hour day with. Yeah. And I've always thought about that. That was a little bit of, I guess, interview advice I took to heart.
天哪，我好喜欢你的戒指。她说，哦，这是海蓝宝石，我是三月出生的。我说，我也是三月出生的。然后我们因为都是双鱼座而产生了一点共鸣。我觉得这些小事非常有帮助。因为记住，公司看重的是你的技能和能力，但他们也必须在个人层面上和你相处。所以，对吧？这种融洽的关系很有帮助。你知道，格雷格·丹尼尔斯曾经告诉我，人们想和他们认为可以一起度过12小时工作日的人一起工作。是的。我一直都在想这件事。我想这算是我铭记在心的一点面试建议。
And then my mom said, when I would go in for a big meeting, a big interview, she would say, you just go in there and you be politely bored. Politely bored. Like, they need to get you interested. Yeah. You're not there to get them interested. Exactly. Oh, that's another way to go, isn't it?
然后我妈妈说，当我参加重要的会议或面试时，她会说，你只要进去，表现得礼貌而无聊就行了。礼貌而无聊。就像是，他们需要让你感兴趣。是的。你不是去让他们感兴趣的。没错。哦，这也是一种方法，不是吗？
But you can still have an icebreaker, but you know, it's that thing that you said where you're taking assessment of them as well. Yes, exactly. All right, my next bit of advice is, you know that you're gonna have to talk about why you're a good fit for the job. Yeah, of all the things they might ask you,
但你仍然可以有一个破冰话题，但你知道，就像你说的，你也在评估他们。是的，没错。好了，我的下一个建议是，你知道你必须谈谈为什么你适合这份工作。是的，在他们可能问你的所有问题中，
we know this is happening. So be prepared, have a self-pitch about yourself that you can say in three sentences. Be sure that it's specific to the job description, to the company that it's not just general, do your homework. Mm-hmm. And finally, especially if you're interviewing
我们知道这肯定会发生。所以要做好准备，准备一段三句话的自我推销。确保它针对职位描述和公司，不要只是泛泛而谈，要做好功课。嗯哼。最后，特别是如果你是第一次面试，
for the first time, or if you haven't interviewed in a while, practice with someone before you go. I did this. I had been going on some general meetings and nothing was happening. And my manager said maybe we should practice the meetings. So we did a practice session and in our practice session, she asked me, what kind of acting are you interested in doing, Jenna? And I gave the answer that I always gave.
或者如果你有一段时间没面试了，去之前先找人练习一下。我就是这样。我参加了一些常规会议，但什么进展都没有。我的经理说也许我们应该练习一下会议。所以我们进行了一次练习，在练习中，她问我，珍娜，你对从事什么样的表演感兴趣？我给出了我一贯的回答。
I would say, well, you know, I love comedy. I love drama. I would be interested in film, television, independent film. I wouldn't say no to a soap opera. I love theater. And she was like, let me stop you right there. This is not the right answer.
我会说，嗯，你知道，我喜欢喜剧。我喜欢剧情片。我对电影、电视、独立电影感兴趣。我不介意演肥皂剧。我喜欢戏剧。她说，让我在这里打断你一下。这不是正确的答案。
I don't know who you are. She said, here's your new answer. Your answer is, I would love to be cast on an Ensemble Comedy Television Series. Yeah, specific. Specific. Yeah. The end.
我不知道你是谁。她说，这是你的新答案。你的答案是，我很乐意出演一部群像喜剧电视剧。是的，具体点。具体点。是的。结束。
Yeah. Because obviously, you can do all these things, but you need to give people a vision of you specifically and what is your main skill? Yeah. And I started doing that and after I did that, my meetings really started to pay off. Yeah. That's my advice. I love it. I love getting specific with things. You know this. Yes. I mean, whether it's a prayer, a meditation, a goal,
是的。因为显然，你可以做所有这些事情，但你需要给人们一个关于你具体形象的愿景，你的主要技能是什么？是的。我开始这样做之后，我的会议真的开始有成效了。是的。这就是我的建议。我喜欢它。我喜欢把事情具体化。你知道这一点。是的。我的意思是，无论是祈祷、冥想还是目标，
get specific. My mom always says get specific with the Lord, you know? But I do, I write out a goal or something I want to pray about. I write it on a post-it note. I put it on my bathroom mirror. I know this about you and I can say in my experience, personally, the more specific I am, the better results I get. Always, always.
都要具体。我妈妈总是说要向上帝具体说明，你知道吗？但我确实会写下一个目标或我想祈祷的事情。我把它写在便利贴上。我把它贴在浴室的镜子上。我了解你这一点，我可以根据我的经验说，个人而言，我越具体，得到的结果就越好。总是这样，总是这样。
So when you're putting it out there, folks, get specific. I would like to add one thing that I did have a job once where I hired people and I also had to fire people. Oh, so you've been on the other side of this? Yes. What advice would you give someone from that position? I would say the minute you arrive, be polite to everyone, because you don't know from the person that held the door open for you, to maybe someone who helped direct where you parked, all of those people that are there matter to who you're interviewing with. Yes, right? That's really good advice. So be respectful to everyone you encounter, no matter what their position you might think, because even though their position might not dictate whether or not you get the job,
所以当你们提出要求时，伙计们，要具体。我想补充一点，我曾经有一份工作，我雇佣过人，也必须解雇过人。哦，所以你也在另一边待过？是的。你会给那个位置的人什么建议？我会说，你一到达，就要对每个人都有礼貌，因为你不知道，从为你开门的人，到可能帮你指引停车位的人，所有在那里的人对你面试的对象都很重要。是的，对吧？这真是个好建议。所以要尊重你遇到的每一个人，无论你认为他们的职位是什么，因为即使他们的职位可能不能决定你是否得到这份工作，
they're important to this company. And then the other thing I would say is, just think about how you smell. Okay. You go to interview with someone you're usually in a smaller office, and your smell will come in with you. Okay.
他们对这家公司很重要。然后我要说的另一件事是，想想你的气味。好的。你去面试时，通常是在一个小办公室里，你的气味会跟着你进来。好的。
It'll be the unique thing that walks in the room with you that sets you apart. Try not to overdo it with the cologne or the perfume. Mm-hmm. Not saying this is gonna rule you out, but there will be a thought that goes through someone's mind of like, oh my gosh, am I gonna have to sit down wind of this person?
这将是和你一起走进房间的独特之处，让你与众不同。尽量不要喷太多的古龙水或香水。嗯哼。不是说这会让你出局，但别人脑子里会闪过一个念头，比如，天哪，我得坐在这个人的下风处吗？
Yeah, am I gonna have to sit with Dracar? Dracar all day. Yeah, yeah. If your sleep is white. Mel proceeds you. Think about it. This is very good advice. We've nailed it.
是的，我得整天和Dracar香水味坐在一起吗？Dracar。是的，是的。如果你的睡眠是白色的。气味先于你到达。想想看。这是非常好的建议。我们做到了。
I think we have. A and Sacramento, good luck. Go get them. Yes, we're rooting for you. Our final question of the day comes from I'm in Oregon. I really feel like Angela Martin would have strong opinions about this one. Okay. And also M, you are talking to three Cat Ladies. Cassie is a Cat Lady. Cassie, are you on? Yes, I'm here. I'm going to want you to weigh in on this too.
我想我们做到了。萨克拉门托的A，祝你好运。去争取吧。是的，我们为你加油。我们今天的最后一个问题来自俄勒冈州。我真的觉得安吉拉·马丁会对这个问题有强烈的看法。好的。而且，M，你正在和三位爱猫女士交谈。凯西是一位爱猫女士。凯西，你在吗？是的，我在这。我也想让你对此发表意见。
Jenna, here we go. M says, I was flabbergasted when a coworker recently asked me to check up on his cats while he was away for three weeks. I have coworkers with whom I have friendships, and this wouldn't be a problem with them. But this male colleague and I have never done much more than a casual chitchat. We've never seen each other outside of work and have never even had lunch together other than a few team lunches paid for by our boss. It also wouldn't have been a problem if we were neighbors.
珍娜，我们开始吧。M说，当一位同事最近在我离开三周期间请我帮忙照看他的猫时，我惊呆了。我有友谊的同事，这对他们来说不是问题。但这位男同事和我除了随意的闲聊之外，没有太多交流。我们从未在工作之外见过面，除了老板请客的几次团队午餐外，甚至从未一起吃过午饭。如果我们是邻居，这也不会是个问题。
I would totally swing by for a cat visit even if I didn't know a neighbor very well. But he lives 25 minutes away from my house. This seems like a bold ask to me. I would never ask a casual work acquaintance such a favor. I told him that I thought it would make better sense for him to ask someone who lived a bit closer to him. What are your thoughts? It was such a strange request that I can't let go of it and my husband is tired of me talking about it. Signed would be Kat's hitter. I'm an Oregon. I mean we know what happened to Angela's cat
即使我不认识邻居，我也会顺便去看看猫。但他住的地方离我家有25分钟的路程。对我来说，这似乎是一个大胆的要求。我永远不会向一个普通的工作熟人提出这样的请求。我告诉他，我觉得他找一个住得近一点的人会更合理。你们怎么看？这是一个如此奇怪的请求，我无法释怀，我丈夫都厌倦我谈论它了。署名：想成为猫保姆。我在俄勒冈州。我的意思是，我们知道安吉拉的猫发生了什么事
when she asked Dwight to watch it once. Frozen in her refrigerator. Yes. I'm with you. I think it's a big ask for someone you don't know that well and who lives far away from you. Well, I would start by saying, I think you handled it well.
当她有一次请德怀特照看它时。冻在她的冰箱里。是的。我站在你这边。我认为对于一个你不那么了解且住得很远的人来说，这是一个很大的要求。嗯，我会先说，我觉得你处理得很好。
Yes. I think, M's big question is, how do I let this go? Yes. Here it was what I thought. I thought maybe this person just doesn't have anyone to ask. Maybe they don't have a lot of friends. Maybe this person views you as one of the nicest people in the office.
是的。我想，M最大的问题是，我该如何放下这件事？是的。这是我的想法。我想也许这个人只是没有人可以问。也许他们没有很多朋友。也许这个人把你视为办公室里最友善的人之一。
I'm not saying this means that you have to do it, you do not have to do it. This is a big ask, it's too far away, it's not convenient. But in terms of just letting it go, maybe there's a way to frame it where you say, oh, maybe this person just doesn't have anyone else. Well, Jenna, you went very zen on that.
我不是说这意味着你必须这样做，你不必这样做。这是一个很大的要求，太远了，不方便。但就放下这件事而言，也许有一种表达方式，你可以说，哦，也许这个人只是没有其他人可以找。嗯，珍娜，你在这方面表现得很禅意。
And you really are taking the moral compass high ground here. And I think you have a good point. Thank you. Cassie. Ooh, this one's tough, but yeah, my, I would say, I'm sorry I can't, and never say why you can't. I think sometimes we feel like we have to come up
你确实在这里占据了道德制高点。我觉得你说得有道理。谢谢。凯西。哦，这个问题很难，但是的，我的，我会说，对不起，我不能，而且永远不要说你为什么不能。我觉得有时我们觉得我们必须想出
with an excuse of like why you can't do something. Oh, yeah. But then yeah, if you want to go above and beyond, maybe you can recommend like a cat service or if you happen to know someone close by or just kind of, yeah, if you feel like they're lonely, you can kind of like brainstorm with them. Like, oh, maybe there's a neighbor that has like a cat in the window
一个借口，比如为什么你不能做某事。哦，是的。但如果你想做得更好，也许你可以推荐一个猫咪服务，或者如果你碰巧认识附近的人，或者只是，是的，如果你觉得他们很孤独，你可以和他们一起集思广益。比如，哦，也许有个邻居窗户里有只猫
and you could talk to them and see if they can help out and That would be great because then when that person goes out of town then they can be like cat sitters for each other Yeah, which is kind of like how I do it when I'm out of town I have people that are like nearby me, so it doesn't feel like such big-ask Yeah, I like that. I think there's a way to frame it to be like first of all Thank you so much for asking me to check on your pet. I know what your pet means to you. So thank you for trusting me with this animal that you care so much about. But because of that commute, I recommend having someone closer to your animal. Yeah, but M is clearly obsessing over why this ask would have been made in
你可以和他们谈谈，看看他们能不能帮忙，那会很棒，因为当那个人出城时，他们就可以互相做猫保姆了。是的，这有点像我出城时的方式。我有住在附近的人，所以感觉不会那么强人所难。是的，我喜欢那样。我觉得有一种表达方式，比如首先，非常感谢你请我照看你的宠物。我知道你的宠物对你意味着什么。所以谢谢你把这只你如此关心的动物托付给我。但因为通勤的原因，我建议找一个离你的动物更近的人。是的，但M显然在纠结为什么会提出这个要求
the first place. Mm-hmm. Like, why me? Why now? I think take it as a compliment. But do not feel guilty for having this boundary. It's totally appropriate that you do not want to drive 25 minutes out of your way to check on your co-workers' cats that you barely know. That's right, that's totally fair. And I think it's also okay that you were thrown by the request. Yes, because I think we would be too. I actually think M did a great job here. Yeah. You did great M and that's from three Cat Ladies.
首先。嗯哼。比如，为什么是我？为什么是现在？我觉得把它当作一种赞美。但不要因为有这个界限而感到内疚。你不想开车25分钟去照看你几乎不认识的同事的猫，这是完全合理的。没错，这完全公平。而且我觉得你被这个请求弄糊涂了也没关系。是的，因为我想我们也会这样。我其实觉得M在这里做得很好。是的。你做得很好，M，这是来自三位爱猫女士的建议。
Well, there you have it. That's our first-deer office ladies. Let's talk about this, Angela. How do you feel now? You've given advice. How do you feel? I mean, I've really enjoyed hearing from people. That's what I love.
好了，就是这样。这是我们的第一期办公室女士。我们来谈谈这个，安吉拉。你现在感觉如何？你给出了建议。你感觉如何？我的意思是，我真的很喜欢听人们的意见。这就是我所爱的。
I love hearing from people. That's what I love. I love hearing from people. I love problem solving about life. You know, I want to know what's in your sauce packet drawer. Yes, you do. Yeah. I enjoyed this as well. So hopefully you did too, and maybe we'll be back for more. And to everyone who's sending their letters, thank you so much.
我喜欢听人们的意见。这就是我所爱的。我喜欢听人们的意见。我喜欢解决生活中的问题。你知道，我想知道你的酱料包抽屉里有什么。是的，你确实想知道。是的，我也很享受这个。所以希望你也一样，也许我们会回来做更多。对于所有寄来信件的人，非常感谢。
Yes, please keep sending in your questions. We're going to keep this up on officeladies.com And Angela, I want to throw something out you. What? I think we got a little confidence here. What do you think? We have people send in any kind of advice question. Oh, no. It doesn't just have to be about work. Oh my god. Do you want to try? Okay, yes. We'll try. All right. So send us your questions and we can't wait to sort it all out with you. I guess we'll be doing this again, so thanks again. And thanks to Jordan for our intro music.
是的，请继续寄来你们的问题。我们会把它保留在officeladies.com上。安吉拉，我想向你提个建议。什么？我觉得我们有点信心了。你觉得呢？我们让人们寄来任何类型的建议问题。哦，不。不一定非要是关于工作的。天哪。你想试试吗？好的，是的。我们会试试。好的。所以把你们的问题发给我们，我们迫不及待地想和你们一起解决。我想我们会再做一次，所以再次感谢。也感谢乔丹为我们制作了开场音乐。
We loved it. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed
我们很喜欢。我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听办公室女士。办公室女士由Earwolf、詹妮弗和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是凯西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制片人是安斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》
Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。